what's going on everybody welcome back
to my youtube channel richard on data if
this is your first time here my name is
richard and this is the channel where we
talk about all things data data science
statistics programming so subscribe to
my channel for all kinds of content on
that kind of good stuff
and hit the notification bell so YouTube
notifies you whenever I upload a video
so anyway a couple weeks ago I did a
video on the state of AI and machine
learning in the year 2020 the company a
pen did a report on all that good stuff
and I went through that report it's a
pretty good detail I thought there were
some pretty interesting findings for it
so check out that video if you haven't
already I'll have a link in the
description as well as a card up above
but anyway so I'm scrolling through
LinkedIn over the weekend and then I
find out that anaconda of all
organizations actually just did a
twenty20 state of data science reports
so now I feel obligated to go through
this one as well except it's not really
an obligation cuz I love going through
this kind of stuff and reading it and
sharing this kind of stuff so so again
not really an obligation so we're we're
gonna go through all this because I
think it's super important for people
who are current data scientists or who
are aspiring to get into the field just
to be aware of what's happening and what
the current trends are so yeah before I
do all that
the usual asks that I do in all of my
videos again subscribe to my channel if
you haven't already hit the like button
to this video because that helps my
content reach a larger audience I have a
patreon link in the description of this
video if your if you guys are willing to
support me that way that will be
massively massively appreciated and also
to those of you who've been subscribed
to me for some time this is the first
time that I've done a video in the style
so streaming what's going on on on
screen while I talk over it with my face
in a corner so let me know how you feel
about this style of video because
usually my videos are much
more heavily edited quite frankly this
kind of style of video is easier to do
so so yeah let me know what you guys
think I'll be very curious yeah so
without further ado let's let's step
through this report again it's from
anaconda on their website this is freely
available and I'll have a link in the
description to this so it's about 38
pages long starting with the methodology
here
they serve a two thousand three hundred
and sixty people for more than 100
countries this was fielded from February
12 to 20 of 2020 so as far as the u.s.
is concerned anyway we got the major
outbreak of the illness about halfway
through this period so I don't know to
what extent that might influence results
here but that's certainly something
that's been affecting the economy as a
whole and just the world as well
respondents were recruited via social
media and the Anaconda email database so
right off the bat that probably produces
a little bit of selection bias as well
as response bias because you're getting
a very specific kind of individual who's
recruited via social media and actually
responding to this kind of thing I can't
think off the top of my head in what way
that influences or creates problems with
the results here necessarily but
probably just something to be aware of
as far as where the responders are
coming from
again it's 2300 people a plurality of
them are coming from North America I
know I have an audience that's in India
my guess is as far as the responders in
Asia a lot of them are probably coming
from India some of them are probably in
Japan and other countries as well but I
bank on a number of them probably being
in India now as far as where they're
coming from education wise and degree
wah and just job level wise
30% of people hold a bachelor's degree
36 percent hold a master's one in five
hold a PhD now I've seen things
indicating that as many as 90% of data
scientists hold a master's degree or PhD
and granted as you see over here not
everybody who are responders here are
data scientists so that probably has
something to do with that all that to
say I'm surprised even 30% of people in
the survey here hold a bachelor's degree
I'm surprised it's not smaller than that
and I'm surprised you don't see a bigger
chunk in the masters and doctorate
degree columns but anyway the biggest
bulk of people here are senior levels
and they're in their organizations
followed by there are a lot of people
who are entry level managers owners
executives c-level types and as far as
the job role kind of thing goes again
the biggest chunk here is data
scientists but there's a decent
representation here from academia like
the next biggest chunk is actually
students and professors and instructors
followed by developers analysts
researchers and engineers are on here -
as far as the industries you've got a
big representation from technology
consulting healthcare and these numbers
don't add up to 100% so you've got a
representation here from from academia
as well I'm assuming that's a big chunk
of the 23% who aren't who aren't
included here as far as where people fit
inside their organization for those of
you who are unfamiliar with the term
data science center of excellence
broadly speaking that refers to a
central cross-functional kind of data
team so that's gonna be our biggest
chunk here followed by data
professionals working in Rd then a
specific line that their business like
HR or marketing a lot of data
professionals work in IT
so then moving on naturally there's a
big data science lifecycle now as far as
where people are spending their time
this is interesting so broadly speaking
data loading and data cleansing you can
pretty much file that under the category
of data wrangling and you guys probably
all know the old joke it goes that 80%
of a data scientists time is spent
cleaning data 20% of their time is spent
complaining about cleaning data so I'm
actually surprised these two together
don't actually make up more than 45% and
I mean obviously the 80% thing that's a
joke so I wouldn't expect this to be 80%
but I'm actually surprised it's only 45%
data visualization is the next big chunk
here 23 percent of time when we when we
group model selection and model training
and scoring together 23 percent of time
together goes to modeling tasks I'm
actually surprised it's not
significantly lower than that 11 percent
of time is spent deploying models to
production now this leaves out some more
exploratory type stuff like maybe if
you're producing like reporting summary
statistics for for data I don't really
know what category this falls under my
guess is either data cleansing or data
visualization but I feel like that's a
chunk of time for a lot of data
professionals that isn't really
represented here so that's pretty
interesting but again you can't escape
the fact 45 percent of people's time is
going to this kind of thing so probably
hopefully in the future people try to
figure out how to reduce this chunk cuz
that's still I mean there's mixed
feelings I have here because this is not
stuff that a lot of people want to be
doing necessarily but it's also
orienting yourself with expectations so
academia does sell a vision of data
science where all this stuff down here
takes up more of your time so part of it
is an expectation kind of thing too so I
don't know those are just broadly my
thoughts on all this this is a pretty
interesting one how often these
languages get used the green category is
always followed by like green is
frequently this Navy ish color is
sometimes the biggest thing by far in a
way that people are using is Python
that's 47 + 28 % + 16% is 91% so 91% of
data professionals from this survey are
using Python and again this is maybe one
of those instances where there's some
bias going on here because anaconda is
broadly speaking and R and Python
distribution platform I don't know if
that's creating a bias here either way
though aren't Python they're the runaway
leaders but Python is running away ahead
of our cuz with our you've got 10% plus
17% plus 20% is 47% that's a very
distant second of people who are using R
and that's pretty consistent with
findings from things like the tayo B
index or indeed job listings all that
indicates there's been a big drop off
since 2018 of people using R so no
surprise is there now I talked about in
my state of AI and ml video that people
may have been using C sharp and C and
C++ more in the data world now this
doesn't indicate that because we've got
12 percent for c-sharp 23 percent for C
or C++ so my guess is because a pen with
their state of AI and machine learning
reports they seem to indicate that more
data professionals were using those
languages
so my guess is for things like deploying
to production there's more emphasis on
these languages compared to our Python
granted you can obviously do that with R
and especially in Python but my guess is
that's to the extent people are using C
sharp and C and C++ they're using them
for deploying to production so for those
of you who are who they know are or
Python or both languages but you don't
know any of these languages based on
this I wouldn't worry too much more on
the toolkit for the mote for the most
part it seems like data scientists are
picking their language of choice based
on convenience so most useful tool for
their need followed by speed of
innovation most economical option is
next I don't know if that means
economical like it's efficient from a
timing standpoint or if it's most
economical from the pricing to their
organization either way it's largely a
convenience kind of thing getting to
production as a as the next big topic
here naturally this is a business
differentiator and data science in some
fee in some industries if not an
absolute requirement in other industries
so when you ask this question what
roadblocks do you face when moving your
models to a production environment and
granted these people here can select
multiple options because these
percentages they're not anywhere close
to adding up to a hundred percent but
the answer is definitely vary from data
scientists to developers to system
administrators probably I mean naturally
because they're working on different
parts of the overall process but data
scientists say their biggest roadblock
is managing dependencies and
environments followed by a skill gap in
their organization followed by meeting
IT security standards so with this one
with managing dependencies and
environments I really wonder how much of
that is a educational thing like how
much universities are actually teaching
this kind of thing because that is more
of a computer science II kind of thing
at least to a certain extent some of it
is probably at the organizational level
to like the data science team and the
organization not understanding how to
make all these things work together like
the prototyping phase and the deployment
to production phase just kind of making
that more of a seamless transition so
how much of that is more of an
organizational education kind of thing I
mean the very next big category that
people are saying is a roadblock is a
skills gap in their organization I can
say from personal experience with
healthcare meeting IT security standards
is a pretty big one just because there's
all kinds of privacy concerns that I
personally experience with healthcare
that can prevent you from taking things
to the level that I know a lot of people
want to I'm certainly not an expert on
data security that's not something that
happens to be in my personal wheelhouse
a lot of the time based on this this
question here on a scale of one to five
how concerned are you about managing
security and vulnerabilities and open
source tools when you ask people this
system administrators business managers
product managers and people who are in
you know the data engineering side of
things they seem a lot more concerned
about this then the data scientists are
look at professors and instructors and
researchers way down at the bottom
that's really not something they seem to
be thinking about on the day-to-day so
that's fascinating now speaking of which
we've got to this question here how do
you ensure open source packages used for
data science and machine
learning meat enterprise security
standards so check this out among those
who knew there who know their employers
approach to security 30 percent report
that they have no mechanism in place to
secure open source pipelines so that
seems very very problematic to me and
again I just admitted that's not
something that's the first thing that
I'm necessarily worried about from day
to day but especially in industries like
healthcare where if you have security
breaches and privacy concerns and big
privacy problems this turns into this
this results in huge fines for the
organization and the bigger the scale
the fine becomes enormous very quickly
so this this to me looks like this could
be a big scandal that happens in the
next one to five years this is the
equivalent this this could turn into
something like like the next Enron
scandal that happens specific to the
data science world and this could happen
in the next one to five years and just
change the way that organizations do
data science in general I don't know I
mean this is this is possible I could
see something like that happening maybe
maybe not well we'll see what happens
this next question in your opinion how
effective is your team at demonstrating
the impact data science has on your
company's business outcomes so if this
is this is polled by industry seventy
one percent of people in consulting say
most of the time are almost always data
science is having a big impact on
business outcomes and that's good
because at least in theory consulting
should be heavily data driven technology
is doing pretty well if we look towards
the bottom we've got education
government health care is dead last at
34 percent and again I've worked in
health care before so this isn't
massively surprising to me and again I
could speak from experience here that
there are a ton of
areas in healthcare to driving serious
business value you have to convince
actual providers at least if we're
working in healthcare at the prevent
with providers putting aside payers for
a second although it's all heavily
interrelated providers can be very set
in their ways they've been practicing
medicine for at times 20 30 maybe even
40 years they're set in their ways they
don't want to change what they're doing
because some model tells them to do so
and again healthcare um you've got all
kinds of security and privacy issues
there which again these are gonna be big
roadblocks for things like model
development getting data deploying
things to production all that stuff so
yeah healthcare has got some pretty
serious problems here and I think it
really says something about your
industry that you're not data data
science is not driving business there
it's driving business even less than in
government so that's that's really
really telling that you're making less
progress than you are even in something
like government um this one is pretty
timely because I just did a video on
data scientists quitting their jobs so
these categories of top are currently
looking and planning to leave the
organization within six to twelve months
so file that all together under people
you can expect to leave the organization
within the next year now I'm not an
expert on this kind of thing because I'm
not involved in my personal
organizations what's the word I'm
looking for retention I like keeping
people around in data science but right
off the bat here this doesn't seem
massively alarming to me like only 29%
of people who are working in R&D they
plan to leave in the next year as far as
the data Science Center of Excellence is
concerned only 36% of data professionals
plan to leave in the next year so again
we keep talking
out there are a shortage of data
scientists out there which means
multiple jobs are competing for the same
data scientists essentially and again
with the illness going around maybe that
landscape changes a little bit because
that the illness has hurt the global
economy to a very great extent but again
I don't know what what numbers HR
professionals look at and they get
scared at but 27 to 30 six percent
doesn't seem massively scary to me
again we're talking about people who are
in very very heavy demand here so again
this is not this doesn't seem that crazy
to me the skills gap between
universities and what enterprises lack
now this is a super fascinating one so
they asked the questions about what
students are learning and what
universities are offering so these two
should be heavily overlapped and to a
great extent they are right we've got
Python and machine learning are in top
categories here so our date of is
probability and statistics deep learning
and advanced mathematics so I guess they
just kind of asked the question a couple
different ways to get different answers
but then as far as what enterprises lack
they're lacking big data management and
they're lacking engineering skills and
these things aren't showing up on the
big categories for what students are
learning and what universities are
offering so look at that we have a gap
between what universities are teaching
and what enterprises say they're lacking
there's no big surprise to me there the
fact enterprises say they're lacking
deep learning and machine learning that
one's interesting to me I'm really
curious if enterprises are lacking more
of the theoretical knowledge kind of
thing that goes into these things or
they're lacking more than knowledge
about how to get these things into
production and to actually see value out
of them because
it seems to me like those are two very
very distinct things and it's
interesting that advanced mathematics is
also on this list of things enterprises
say they're lacking so that could
indicate when people say they're lacking
deep learning and machine learning
that's kind of the problem
I don't know I I kind of feel like I
need to know more about this because
this is uh this is this this brings a
lot of questions to mind from me this
question here about what's the biggest
obstacle to obtaining your ideal data
science job the biggest thing is
experience that's that it's not
surprising in the slightest to me again
I make fun of on my channel all the time
these jobs they don't know what they're
doing they list 20 different
technologies that people need to be
familiar with that just indicates that
they don't know what they're doing but I
understand - people need to get their
foot in the door they need to kind of
know what they're doing before they can
get hired - so is the university
preparing them is it giving them the the
skills in Python and are this this here
I mean that looks that looks optimistic
and I'm glad that universities are
offering Python and that students are
learning it because it seemed in the
past like academia had more of a and
more of a push towards are but as
industry goes to a more python-based
direction it's good that universities
seem to be doing that as well sorry I'm
skipping around all over the place here
technical skills is an obstacle skipping
ahead a little bit here - the biggest
problems to tackle in the AI and machine
learning area again impacts to
individual privacy were a big thing
again that could turn into a big scandal
in the in the next few years I think if
if that many data professionals are not
doing anything about it
now this next one as far as social
impacts from bias and data and models
just a little bit of an over
you on that and there are tons and tons
of examples from that but let me just
come up with a simple easy to explain
example of that for those of you who
haven't thought about this issue before
so let's just say you're working on
something like a predicting for a
customer base how likely people are to
default on a loan so it could be the
case that you have your black
respondents they are more likely
compared to your white respondents to
default on a loan so let's say you're
training a model and you're using race
as an input to your model so that might
end up making your model more accurate
just based on the sample that you have
but it's going to end up as a very
vicious cycle kind of thing where as a
result of that input which was used to
make the model more accurate you have
more black people compared to white
people being declined loans because this
model says they're more likely to or
it's the model is saying the black
recipients are more likely to default on
the loans so that's just an example that
I just came up with just now I'm sure
there are tons and tons of examples out
there but yeah that's that's a pretty
big thing which it's it's easy to use a
little bit of imagination and just see
where that could turn into some pretty
huge problems fairness and explain
ability are our big issues that's
especially the case with things like
let's say in that example that I just
used
there's no explain ability that's going
on whatsoever the impact that race has
on how the model was put together I mean
if the model is a neural network which
is already a totally black box model
yeah forget about it forget about trying
to trying to go before the broader
population and public and explain that
like that's it's very easy to see how
that's gonna cause problems as far as
the data
science teams working on solutions to
address data bias or model explained
ability seems broadly like people are
pretty slow to address this kind of
thing fairness and bias mitigation only
30 and 38 percent of respondents say
they've already implemented a solution
or they're planning to within the next
12 months 54 percent of responders say
they've done so so looks like people are
a little sore a little behind the ball
on that one so again maybe this turns
into another big scandal within the next
couple years and it's very possible so
we could see some big changes to the
data science field based on these kinds
of issues in the next few years here
again there seems to be a lot of
evidence that looking ahead and this is
kind of just a summary overall to this
report value realization getting data
science outputs into production will
become increasingly important requiring
leaders and data scientists alike to
remove barriers to deployment and data
scientists to learn to communicate the
value of their work yes so a lot of this
is just getting yourself familiar with
the business environment as a whole
being able to communicate that and
getting educated on the actual element
of deploying models into production it
seems like to a great extent that's
something that's not getting covered a
lot within colleges and universities so
that's a little bit problematic but
that's important now and it's gonna be
even more important as we move into into
the coming years of this decade
integrating open source technology so
we've got organizations should take a
proactive approach to integrating open
source solutions into the development
pipeline ensuring that data scientists
do not have to use their preferred tools
outside of the policy boundary yeah so
this gets back to some of the topics
earlier here about making sure people
aren't switching from one language to
the other let's actually be able to
deploy models into production using our
thawne like switching switching from one
tool to another is grossly grossly
inefficient so hopefully there's not a
lot of that going on and to the extent
we can use those open-source tools like
R or Python to deploy models into
production that's a good thing hopefully
we can do that talent development
acquisition and retention that seems
incredibly broad and I feel like each
one of those three could be its own
slide here they even say it here the
talent issue has numerous dimensions and
the most successful organizations will
address it from multiple angles yeah as
we saw before there is a gap between
what people are learning in universities
and what enterprises are requiring it's
actually not as horrible as I thought it
was but hopefully universities are
taking note I think the fact that a lot
of universities are developing data
science specific programs that's an
extremely good thing and I think in a
lot of universities that makes sense for
people and I've said in a lot of videos
having a strong statistics base is
important but so is knowing programming
and deploying models into production
these are these are important things to
employers should look beyond
compensation and design holistic data
science talent retention strategies
focused on helping data scientists gain
experience articulating the value of
their work yes absolutely
data scientists should have some degree
of understanding of how business
operates and how data science helps
these businesses generate revenue I feel
like that's kind of a gap with a lot of
colleges and universities so I'm a big
big fan of internships because it'll
just bring a lot of much-needed
perspective say you're like in a
master's program you have an internship
in the summer after your first year and
then you come back
I think when you go into your second
year having done an internship in the
middle there will bring some really
really helpful perspective and they say
here finally employers to take seriously
the business value of cross-training in
the short term organizations can cross
train and up skill domain expert
employees and modern data science
methodologies and tools to improve
outcomes yeah I mean I think the career
trajectory for a lot of data scientists
involves becoming a domain expert
particularly if you've been in the same
domain for like eight to ten years and
you happen to be extremely technolog
technologically savvy on top of that and
I think I think that's gonna be an
incredibly lucrative career trajectory
and an overall job in general as we move
into this decade looking beyond
compensation is definitely important
because I mean let's face it to keep to
retain and attract talent in the first
place
yeah these companies they have to cough
up big money but I just covered this in
my in my video about data scientists
leaving their jobs a big thing a big
thing which people are citing and
complaining about is lack of upskilling
opportunities you have to know a lot of
different skills in the data science
field so if you just feel stagnated and
like you're you haven't been learning
anything in the next six to twelve
months yeah I mean you're you're
probably gonna gonna want to leave your
job or at least you're gonna look at
what's out there and and just really ask
yourself some pretty serious questions
about if you want to stick around bias
mitigation and explain ability we see an
opportunity for data professionals to
exert leadership within their
organizations and drive change yeah
absolutely I mean this is certainly
something that should be encouraged and
they say here we were troubled to find
39% of enterprises do not have a plan to
implement solutions for bias mitigation
27% of have no plans to tackle explain
ability yeah for those of you who are
current or aspiring data scientists yeah
I mean find opportunities in you where
you're in your organization to address
this problem and I mean really ask
yourself is this a big problem say
you're working on a model could there be
some real social consequences to the
work that you're doing is the work that
you're doing creating good for society
as a whole I mean really ask yourself
that question don't just don't just go
to your job for a paycheck or to work on
cool models really ask yourself that
question I mean I'm a millennial myself
I think my generation we asked this kind
of question a lot I mean it's not enough
for us to earn a paycheck we really want
to do good by the world a lot of times
whether we're successful in doing that
as a separate question but yeah I mean
this is an opportunity to really be a
thought leader in in your company and in
data science in general so yeah that
that wraps it up um again I think
there's a couple things here which were
maybe in red flag territory like the
security stuff and the model explain
ability and bias stuff we could see
scandals as we move forward but overall
again I think the I think the future as
we go into data science it it's looking
extremely bright so there's nothing here
that was enormous ly surprising to me
but yeah this is this is just a broad
good comprehensive overview I think of
the trends that are going on in data
science and yeah I think I've said my
piece and I'll just leave it there so
thanks to everybody for for watching
this video again let me know what you
think about I mean really everything
here let me know if you found anything
surprising and again let me know if you
found if let me know if you enjoy this
style of video on my part because again
this is really fun and easy for me to
make as usual again hit the hit the like
button so my content can reach a larger
audience and yeah then I'll see you guys
all in the not so distant future until
then Richard on data